à l'aéroport international de moscou
c'est l'effervescence des grands jours
après quatre mois de fermeture à cause
du coronavirus les vols internationaux
ont repris un soulagement pour ses
passagers mon premier vol était censé
avoir lieu le 6 juillet mais il n'a
cessé d'être reporté donc j'attends
depuis cette date je cherche un billet
depuis le mois de mai car j'ai besoin de
voir ma famille et mes parents le fait
qu'il y ait beaucoup d'incertitudes me
rend nerveux
j'attends ce jour depuis quatre mois
donc je suis contente même si je suis
aussi un peu inquiète de la façon dont
tout se passera en termes de contrôle de
documents et tout ça mais je suis
vraiment heureuse la vie normale est de
retour d'autres aéroports des régions de
moscou de saint pétersbourg et de rostov
sur le don sont également concernés par
cette reprise du trafic aérien
international
une reprise qui s'étend également à
d'autres secteurs d'activité comme les
loisirs
devant cette mythique salle de cinéma à
moscou les cinéphiles sont enfin de
retour
cela fait quatre mois qu'ils attendent
ce moment
alors pas question de manquer cette
première séance même programmé à minuit
pile
nous attendons depuis mars le moment
nous pourrons enfin aller au cinéma pour
de vrai à partir de demain nous
présenterons dix nouveaux films en
salles et nous prévoyons de sortir un
certain nombre de grands films russes à
la fin du mois d'août et en septembre
les spectateurs doivent observer des
mesures sanitaires strictes
prise de température masque obligatoire
à l'entrée et respect des distances
entre chaque groupe à l'intérieur il est
intéressant d'observer comment les gens
s'assoient ici toutes les exigences de
sécurité sont respectées
vous pouvez mettre votre sac à dos à
côté de vous mais c'est dommage que les
salles de cinéma ne puisse pas se
remplir entièrement à moscou la menace
d'une deuxième vague est donc dorénavant
lointaine c'est ce qu'a en effet affirmé
sergueï sobianine le maire de la ville
la deuxième vague c'est quand les gens
risquent une deuxième fois d'être
affectés ce genre de cas est quasiment
inexistant aussi bien chez nous que dans
le livre pourquoi constatons une
croissance aussi rapide dans certaines
régions parce qu'ils n'ont même pas
franchi la première vague le premier
processus où elle était enfermée comme
hong kong avec un confinement congrès
des villes comme londres
new york paris moscou ont déjà franchi
cette étape pour endiguer la pandémie
elle les autorités misent désormais sur
deux vaccins élaborés par des chercheurs
russes dont les essais cliniques ont
pris fin il devrait permettre dès le
mois d'octobre de vacciner massivement
la population